this video is proudly sponsored by
Squarespace stick around until the end
of the video to learn more about a deal
they're making available through my
channel
let's get the elephant out of the room
you don't need any supplements in order
to build lots of muscle and feel amazing
you can and probably should start off
without using supplements if you're a
beginner that said for the right person
a few supplements can make a big
difference and help to optimize yourself
and get a little extra Edge out of your
training it's gonna be different for
everyone but I'm going to share some of
the supplements that helped me to think
and feel much better
these are things that will improve your
physical performance they'll help you to
gain a little bit more muscle recover
slightly better but also improve your
energy levels and your mental Clarity
and focus what you'll find is actually a
lot of things that Boost Physical
performance also have cognitive benefits
including some classic supplements that
you likely didn't know had as many
benefits for the entire body Beyond just
training so let's start with an obvious
one creatine not the most exciting
supplement but actually maybe it should
be creatine recycles used ATP that's
adenosine triphosphate so that you can
use it again and this gives you just a
little bit more energy before you switch
Energy Systems basically meaning you get
an extra rep out of your training in
some cases or stay on the treadmill just
for a little bit longer this is really
useful obviously for increasing your
work capacity but it also has other
benefits creatine increases water
retention in the muscles and can add
some visible muscle mass different
people respond to this differently but
for me personally it is actually quite a
visible change and when I'm using
creatine I look bulkier but it goes Way
Beyond this because creatine increases
your ability to use energy efficiently
actually also boosts brain function and
Studies have shown that using creatine
can actually increase your IQ by a
couple of points obviously an imperfect
measure of intelligence but still
there's something useful going on here
beyond that it can also raise DHT
dehydrotestosterone some people are
concerned that this is then going to
lead to hair loss but there's no
evidence to suggests this is the case
and that hair loss is only going to
occur if you already have a genetic
predisposition and on top of that it can
also boost satellite cells which is a
way to increase muscle mass not only in
the short term but potentially in the
long term as you increase your ability
to synthesize protein and build muscle
so yeah creatine really important you
can get it from meat but it's much
easier and more convenient to take a
supplement similarly omega-3 fatty acid
nothing new but does way more than you
might have realized now one of the main
things that omega-3 is popular for is
increasing cell membrane permeability
that means that these cell walls allow
things to pass through slightly more
easily and this can improve things like
cell transmission so you can actually
increase the speed of your cognition
potentially again boosting IQ at the
same time it can also reduce
inflammation if you have too much
omega-6 compared with omega-3 then
you're going to have inflammation and
because a lot of people get far more
omega-6 in their diet than omega-3
taking over three can reduce
inflammation not only helping you to
reduce pain and discomfort potentially
also combating things like brain fog
because inflammation in the brain May
contribute to brain fog and on top of
that omega-3 can also do pretty much all
kinds of things it can improve
myelination it can thicken the
insulation of the axons of your cells
your neurons allowing once again
Transmissions to go through more
efficiently omega-3 is something that
should be in your diet great for brain
function also potentially useful for
building muscle
so when you're less likely to have heard
of necessarily is magnesium three and
eight so magnesium 3 and 8 is a form of
magnesium that's been shown to more
effectively cross the blood brain
barrier and the reason we're interested
in this is because that in turn makes it
once again useful for enhancing brain
plasticity brain plasticity again being
the essentially the adaptability of the
brain the ability to learn new things
and to change in response to experience
which is huge in terms of cognitive
performance at the same time magnesium
is a very important ingredient when it
comes to synthesizing testosterone so if
you want to boost your testosterone
levels then magnesium along with zinc is
one of the first things to look at and I
personally feel as though magnesium 3
and 8 does elevate my testosterone could
be Placebo but I do feel a little bit
more spring in my step and let's just
say in the mornings I need to stay in
bed a little bit longer before I get up
and greet my children finally magnesium
of course is very good for relaxing the
muscles many people will take it before
bed for this reason to help them get to
sleep but in general it can age with
recovery and helped combat stress so
I've mentioned a couple of supplements
here that can boost testosterone but I
do just want to take a moment to say
don't focus on that too much I think a
lot of people waste a lot of time
chasing ways to optimize their
testosterone production thinking it's
going to make them suddenly super strong
and energetic and masculine whereas in
reality a little bit of testosterone
isn't going to make a huge difference
from most people and most supplements
aren't going to do all that much to your
levels yeah you might be bucking up the
wrong tree if you spend too much time
worrying about all these ways to
optimize testosterone when you should
just be working out
when thinking about what kind of
supplements you want to take it's
important to know what the end goal is
what you want to feel like at the end
and I think a mistake is to want to feel
you know energized and buzzed and this
isn't the right way to go this is why I
don't personally get on particularly
well with pre-workouts if you're feeling
buzzed then you're not performing
naturally on the other hand if your
supplementation your nutrition your
recovery is all on point you should just
feel like you are like a really good day
where you don't notice yourself feeling
sluggish and to that end I really like
these two products I've talked about
them before phosphatidylserine and
inositol and these are both things that
I find can really help with things like
burnout and even they've been shown to
improve ADHD symptoms so in the case of
inositol it increases the density of
neurotransmitter receptors in the brain
basically the parts of your neurons that
react to neurotransmitters these can be
diminished through things like over
training or even the use of other
supplements and by having more of these
you react better to the
neurotransmitters flowing through your
brain so this is a great way to get a
boost without actually just you know
artificially elevating something like a
dopamine and meanwhile
phosphatidylserine can improve your
natural production of some of these
chemicals so yeah in general focusing
more on recovery can be a really good
strategy because if you recover better
you can train harder and feel better and
perform better and phosphatidylserine in
particular has been shown to improve
recovery from exercise induced stress so
if you're someone who finds yourself
often burning out or over training then
this might be a good thing to take as
well One supplement that's been getting
a lot of attention lately is Alpha GPC
this is a choline source and your brain
uses choline to produce acetylcholine
this is a primary neurotransmitter
basically allows for more action within
the brain communication between brain
cells so it can again improve your focus
but also because acetalk coding is so
important for the neuromuscular Junction
it may also improve strength and force
production in fact one study found that
using a little bit of alpha GPC could
improve jump height by 8.5 percent now
there's a little bit of concern over
time Alpha GPC usage could Elevate tmao
levels but the evidence surrounding this
is inclusive I think if you're using
just a little bit as part of a
pre-workout or just a an additional
supplement it's not going to be an issue
for most people so this is the only
thing that I use as a sort of
pre-workout but I do recommend you do
your own research here and again that
goes for everything on this list of
course there are loads of honorable
mentions most people are going to
benefit from taking an extra protein
source for example like whey protein
this just makes it a convenient way to
get protein you don't need a protein
shake but if you want a more convenient
and affordable way to get more protein
in your diet that's really good option
vitamin D is really good and proves
testosterone production bone strength at
the same time things like vitamin B
complex can be really useful there's
loads out there like I say don't need
any of them but many people are going to
find they have some kind of deficiency
or they respond particularly well to
something so don't spend loads of money
on a massive supplement stack but
sometimes experimenting can be
worthwhile
things like the protein shake the
creatine the omega-3 fatty acid I think
everyone can benefit from some of these
options are more things that I've had
some use with but they won't be useful
for everyone like the phosphat is still
Serene and the inositol and that's
something to bear in mind supplements
react differently to different people
you won't know if something's going to
be effective for you until you try it
but if you feel great then you probably
don't need it let me know what
supplements you guys take in the
description down below I'd love to hear
it thank you so much for watching this
one guys huge thanks to grant for
filming he's done an awesome job as
usual check out the link to his channel
in the description down below and I'll
see you next time thanks a ton for
watching
bye for now
but what are you gonna do with that
brain now that it's optimized for
productivity and performance well how
about building a website with today's
sponsor Squarespace anyone can build a
website with zero coding skills
necessary the first thing you'll do is
pick from a huge selection of modern
adaptable templates which takes no time
at all from there you can customize your
site and add a whole slew of
professional features you can easily
publish posts or schedule them for later
there's a fully integrated commenting
system with threaded replies likes and
more there's Advanced member management
their social media integration so you
can display your social posts directly
on your home page you can even generate
Revenue with members-only gated content
or how about selling products via
powerful e-commerce tools if you need
even more features you can pick from a
huge number of plugins examples include
sales tax reconciliation streamlined
bookkeeping tracking for international
shipping and inventory management the
sky is the limit with Squarespace and I
genuinely believe everyone can benefit
from having their own website although
that's for your personal use to
kick-start your career or to set up a
side hustle go to squarespace.com to
find out more and when you're ready to
get started go to squarespace.com
forward slash bioneer to get 10 off the
purchase of your first website or domain
thanks again to Squarespace and bye for
now